yeah so the only thing I was going to
add there is to Rich's point about you
know those guys are like oh I can't do
it or it must be easy me and Jared have
seen this we see this all the time like
we go through comment sections or we see
guys that are like uh you guys are
always talking about you know the top 10
percent of guys the top 20 of guys but
what about like the guys that are in the
middle what is your advice for guys in
the 50 percentile like are we supposed
to be there no we just don't get to have
girls like yeah dude like yeah you don't
exist you're not on their radar you're
invisible so you either change your
plight and you get to the top one of
your top ten or you can just have
mediocre results and be a loser for the
rest of your life like you know I I
don't I don't care about living in the
this is how should be life should be a
world because too many people want to
think oh what shouldn't be that way it's
like it doesn't matter what you should
or should not be the only thing that
matters is how life is and you either
can play by those rules or not play or
don't play but changing the game is not
an option and the game
they want to pull you down to their
level because then it makes exactly
better right
because it's harder to do the work to
level up to get to here it's easier for
them to pull you down here right
although let's not do not have noticed
it's really not hard to do the work I
was on a stream last night and someone
asked like oh how'd you lose all the
weight was it really tough like it was
tough to realize I needed to lose the
weight but once I had in my head like
I'm gonna be [__] hot and jacked it
just happened it's not hard how'd you
quit drinking uh I looked like a fat ass
alcoholic in the mirror and I hated what
I saw so I changed it period done well I
don't understand why it's so hard for
people to do this [__] like do you want
it I really want it I take another
interception
another another misconception is that
everybody has got to be jacked with a
Supercar and dating a 10 as we've gone
over to a million times it's been the
best version of yourself you know
exactly
yes all of us you know the group of us
that were skiing in Colorado this year
or one buddy that came with us you know
he looks like he can doll and we're all
like we could be in the gym 24 7 365 and
have three dietitians none of us would
look like that guy
um
really overestimate like what where they
are so even when we talk about best
version of yourself I mean be actually
like most guys tend to undercut
themselves but I go back to the guy Rich
you had on your show this past Monday
Bob and you know learning about his
story and learning and seeing his
Instagram and kind of knowing his
background and listening to that cast
and the guy still valued himself at like
a 6.5 I'm like dude there's no way in
hell that you're a point and a half
above average so it's like you know you
know the delusion with a lot of guys
still is very strong that's awesome
I noticed with men they tend to
undervalue their value whereas women
tend to overvalue their value and our
friend Bob the incel overvalued you know
as smv because yeah you're right he call
them a 6.5 I'd probably put them at a
three
um only because he was decently good
looking but it was like basic
fundamental [__] like going to the gym
was like over his head
um you know what I told them don't do it
because it's hard yeah you know when I
told them you know get into Combat
Sports because that shit's good for you
it's like you know I said you know at
least try cry for 90 days like commit to
90 days like well maybe I'll do 30. it's
like oh [__] it's like you know like are
you gonna [__] like listen to any of
what I'm saying here it's like Bob would
you sleep with yourself yeah I would
yeah no you would I mean
anybody can take from that cap yes
that's how lazy you know your
competition is right it's like just dude
like get out there and and start
grinding and get your head down I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out